cative nous allons à kunheim à
l'établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées et dépendantes
ils organisaient leur semaine citoyenne
une première sur le territoire français
voici le reportage des personnes en tee
shirt jaune se sont emparés de
l'établissement d'hébergement pour
personnes âgées dépendantes la roselière
à kunheim
il s'agit de bénévoles le temps d'une
semaine
ils sont venus participer à divers
travaux à l'occasion de la semaine
citoyenne
c'est la deuxième année que les
résidents assistent à cette initiative
une initiative unique en france pour un
établissement pour personnes âgées alors
au niveau national l'année dernière nous
étions le premier établissement
la première maison de retraite en france
organisé une semaine citoyenne
au départ l'idée nous est venue tout
simplement puisque il ya des communes
qui organise déjà des semaines citoyenne
on a dit pourquoi pas créer une semaine
citoyenne au sein de la maison de
retraite
justement qui répondent aux mêmes
critère qu'une journée citoyenne
classique c'est-à-dire de faire faire de
faire réaliser des travaux à des
bénévoles au sein de la maison de
retraite dans un but bien évidemment
d'économies mais surtout je dirais de
solidarité vis-à-vis des personnes âgées
de la maison de retraite le lundi matin
le directeur de la roselière accueille
chaleureusement les bénévoles et leur
présente l'établissement créé en 1993 ne
sont plus de 200 bénévoles à s'être
mobilisés pour cette semaine un peu
particulière
muriel gigli animatrice corps d'un des
différents ateliers du groupe de travail
les gens ont pu s'inscrire selon le
temps qu'ils disposent ça peut être par
demi journée par journée entière une
journée de journée en fonction de leurs
plannings et on a différents chantiers
différents ateliers de prévu dans la
semaine et donc ils ont pu s'inscrire
aux dépens des ateliers comme de la
peinture nettoyage les vitres est de
repas participation aux animations etc
ainsi en fonction de son temps libre à
chacun peut venir donner un coup de main
djazouli un petit peu parce qu'elles
travaillent tellement bien toutes ces
dames mais moi j'ai plus mes parents
alors je peux aussi faire un peu de
temps pour les autres personnes puis
quand on a un petit peu de temps je
pensais bien leur en donner aux autres
allez
ça m'occupe plus j'aime bien la joie du
monde je suis pas celle de ma tanière et
puis j le partage on sent utile bon j'ai
ma mère qui est ici et je veux le
programme il convenait et congés temps
libre et problème
ce projet lui sans laisser aux divers
genres entre affaires dans le jardin et
pourquoi ne pas aider d'autres
certains sont des habitués mais c'est
aussi un moyen de découvrir la vie d'une
maison de retraite
on découvre à voir les gens qui
travaillent qui ce qui tournait les
compétences ils ont tous pauvres de
foyers la kiné je vois les
ergothérapeutes j'ai vu des psychologues
que avant je n'avais pas jamais pu
croire que ça existe dans les maisons de
retraite et donc nous a proposé une
journée citoyenne très bonne idée pour
une journée son boys ou deux jours selon
veut ou la semaine d'au moins timides se
dit bon première année je vais aller le
premier jour et c'était lundi et les
lundis après-midi fin de matinée j'étais
déjà descendu chez muriel jquery est ce
que j'ai le droit de revenir demain le
mardi soir pareil tout cela dit j'ai
fait ça jusqu'à vendredi
c'est tellement intéressant
un moyen de découvrir l'établissement
mais aussi de tisser des liens
on déjeune ensemble et l'ambiance y est
conviviale pour donner un petit coup de
main
les personnes qui ont besoin est petit
[Musique]
ça
oh
il ya certes des travaux qui sont
effectués il ya également des bénévoles
qui assistent aux animations avec les
personnes âgées un des animations
classiques qui sont organisées çà de la
maison de retraite il ya surtout ces
échanges qui se réalise de manière tout
à fait spontanée entre personnages et et
bénévoles tout au long de la journée et
qui amin qui amène énormément de vie au
sein de la maison de retraite
l'implication des bénévoles de tous les
âges qu'ils soient retraités étudiants
ou faisant par exemple partie de la
mission locale des jeunes apportent de
l'animation c'est un peu la société qui
entrent dans la maison de retraite ici
l'individualisme a mis de côté chacun
devient acteur fabien jourdan initiateur
de la journée citoyenne dans l'économie
il ya plus de dix ans encourage ses
belles actions enfin quand le sentiment
est ce que ce qu'on voulait produire par
la journée citoyenne c'est juste la
fierté de participer
et quand on voit les gens qui s'y
impliquent ici aujourd'hui on sent cette
fierté de participer et c'est vrai que
c'est parti d'une petite commune
berrwiller dans le haut-rhin et
maintenant c'est sur 1200 villes en
france avec deux cent mille personnes
impliquées l'année dernière et cette
année encore plus juste dans un esprit
de simplicité juste faire pour l'autre
une belle évolution qui encourage le
département à étendre cette action dans
d'autres maisons de retraite au conseil
départemental souhaitons aventurier un
petit peu toutes les belles initiatives
qui se déroule dans notre département
pour voir comment les transposer dans
d'autres établissements ce qui se passe
que on a une première journée citoyenne
mais dans les faits les autres jaunes
mais deviennent citoyen'' aussi puisque
on se rend compte que les bénévoles qui
viennent qui s'investissent aujourd'hui
vont peut-être revenir
donc monsieur directeur me confirmer
tout à l'heure on revenir dans l'année
pour se mettre à disposition et pour
mettre en oeuvre pour se mettre au
service de la collectivité les autres
jours de l'année aussi la présidente du
département s'est également associé à
cette action en la soutenant et en
s'investissant personnellement je
souhaite pour ma part développé ce
concept à travers tout le département
dans les autres ehpad j'ai l'intention
également de de développer la journée
citoyenne auprès des collégiens pour que
les jeunes soient très vite sensibiliser
à l'engagement citoyen c'est un vrai
enjeu pour pour l'avenir en tout cas je
souhaiterais remercier de tout coeur les
équipes de la roselière et aussi tous
ces bénévoles qui durant la semaine vont
ici s'engager auprès des personnes âgées
parce que c'est ça demande beaucoup de
temps là je donne le petit déjeuner à
cette dame depuis presque vingt minutes
donc si on passe une demi heure par par
résidence et c'est juste énorme et de
l'apport des bénévoles est considérable
alors je fais vraiment appel à toutes
les personnes qui ont un peu de temps et
donner c'est juste un bon moment à
passer avec les personnes âgées
[Musique]
c'est absolument génial parce que on le
fait dans les ehpad maintenant et ça
permet aussi aux gens de se connaître
d'apprendre aux jeunes à voir les
personnes âgées créer du lien
intergénérationnel et on le fait
également dans les collèges parce que
c'est cette jeune génération qui qu'il
faut mettre au goût du jour le civisme
le respect le partage de données avant
de vouloir recevoir et c'est ça qui est
essentiel c'est juste apprendre à
connaître l'autre pour le respecter
davantage lors de la semaine bleue
semaine dédiée consacré aux personnes
âgées dans le département la roselière
témoignera de cette action qui suivra à
son chemin auprès des autres maisons de
retraite
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]